good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight
happy good friday if you can say that
always a sort of mixed day and today was
no different a radical black nationalist
drove a car into two police officers
near the capitol in washington this
afternoon
one of the officers was killed along
with a suspect now it's interesting
there's still
much we don't know about this we know
very little but this is one
high-profile murder that didn't somehow
set off an avalanche of hysterical media
attacks on an entire racial group you
didn't see stories about
how all black people are bad or
blackness is a virus
and thank god that stuff is garbage it's
poison
all decent people hate it attacking
entire races
is evil no matter what the race is it's
really hurting the country and the
people in power should stop doing it
today for once they didn't do it thank
god for small blessings but that doesn't
mean
our leaders turned down the opportunity
to leverage the tragedy of course they
did
ilhan omar immediately called for gun
control even the assailant apparently
didn't have a gun but just a knife she's
not a genius as we've noted before
then the usual experts told us the
lesson was we need even more
barbed wire around the capitol it's too
open to the public they said
to keep our democracy safe we must wall
off voters from the leaders who
supposedly represent them
well that's already happening of course
across the country both
physically in the green zone-style
barriers you suddenly see everywhere
around government buildings
and also on a far deeper level on a
level that can't be undone
as quickly as a fence in a democracy the
people rule
if voters want something done over time
it happens that's what self-government
is but what do you call a system in
which all the major all the really
important decisions are made by big
companies
without any reference at all to what
voters want
well that is not democracy it's
corporatocracy
and it's starting to look a lot like
what we have now here's the latest
example
major league baseball announced today
it's pulling two of the biggest events
in sports the all-star game and the mlb
draft
out of the state of georgia why is major
league baseball weighing in on this why
is it doing it
well because voters in the state of
georgia made a decision that the biden
administration
doesn't like and as with so many big
corporations major league baseball
believes it now has
veto power over the democratic process
and by the way it may have veto power
we'll find out
in the case of georgia the state passed
a law to reduce voter fraud
that law requires voters to provide some
form of identification before they cast
a mail-in ballot
that identification could be a driver's
license or free state provided
id georgia makes it pretty easy to prove
who you are
there's nothing crazy about this law in
fact it's hard to believe it wasn't
already on the books in georgia it
should have been
but when it was proposed it sailed
through the state house georgia's house
of representatives approved this bill by
a 25-vote margin the state senate by a
vote of 34-24
so unlike say obamacare it wasn't a
squeaker
and you can see why nationally the
overwhelming majority of americans
agree with it they support mandatory
photo id
for voting according to a recent poll by
the ap
fully 72 percent of people in this
country believe that
required ids are a good idea
and why wouldn't they think that you
already have to show an id when you fly
in a plane or
drive a car open a checking account hold
a job live in an apartment or get a
vaccine
but you don't need one to vote come on
it's ridiculous
in fact it's worse than ridiculous it is
sinister
anyone who opposes voter id laws is
encouraging voter fraud which is to say
encouraging the destruction of democracy
it's that simple and you can now put
major league baseball
in that category now baseball was
supposed to be america's pastime
happy unifying fundamentally
non-political so it's strange to see
this happen
how do we get here it's not at all
complicated
we have a new president now and that
president is willing to destroy even
something as wholesome as the country's
traditional game
purely to increase the power of his
political party
just the other day joe biden went on
espn to demand that professional sports
franchises boycott
any state whose voters step out of line
i think today's professional athletes
are acting incredibly responsibly
i would strongly support them doing that
people look to them
their leaders look at what's happened
with the nba as well
look what's happened across the board
the very people who are victimized
the most are the people who are the
leaders in these
in these various sports and it's just
not right
this is jim crow on steroids what
they're doing in
in georgia and 40 other states
so that's the considered judgment
expressed out loud by the president
united states
georgia's voter id law is jim crow on
steroids
asking people to show their identity
before they vote is worse than
segregation and lynching
it's bull connor and fire hoses and
snarling german shepherds
on steroids you gotta wonder how long
our leaders can keep saying things like
this
reckless things like this before they
really cause the society to fall apart
joe biden seems determined to find out
one thing biden doesn't seem very
interested in is his
own home state delaware unlike georgia
delaware has never
permitted mass early voting apparently
delaware is a white supremacist state
about 80 percent of georgia voters cast
their ballots early in
last fall in delaware that number was 29
so why isn't that voter suppression why
isn't it racism
well because delaware is a one-party
state controlled by the democrats it's
working for them they're not going to
change it georgia by contrast is a swing
state
so in the estimation of joe biden it is
worth using
racially divisive lies to win it for his
party permanently
according to joe biden the real problem
with georgia's new election law is that
it could cause dangerous dehydration
what i'm worried about is how unamerican
this whole initiative is it's sick
it's sick deciding in some states that
you cannot
bring water to people standing in line
waiting to vote deciding that
you're going to end voting at five
o'clock when working people are just
getting off work every word of that was
false maybe the washington post will
start a joe biden lie
meter just kidding in fact the georgia
law
bans political organizations from
bringing gifts to people who are
standing in line to vote that's called
electioneering it is banned in an awful
lot of places probably where you live
but there is no prohibition in georgia
or anywhere else against people getting
water and food in line if it comes from
someone other than a political operative
if it comes from a friend or family
member for example and by the way
they can also bring their own water
hydrating is still legal
in georgia as for the claim that this
law will end
voting at five o'clock that's a lie too
wait a second joe biden just said that
on tv so where did he get the idea
voting ends at five o'clock well it
turns out that the big paper in atlanta
the atlanta journal constitution
reported that the law would ban voting
after five o'clock
the paper's reporters apparently hadn't
read the law they had to
append this correction to their piece
which effectively was the same as
admitting they were repeating
talking points without doing any
research which is what they were doing
here it is quote
a previous version of this story said
the new law would limit voting hours on
election day in georgia polling places
are open from 7 am
to 7 pm and if you're in line by 7 pm
you are allowed to cast your ballot
nothing in the new law changes those
rules end quote
that's the truth finally appended to a
lie
now joe biden got his research on that
bill from reporters who did no research
see how that works today at the white
house press briefing one reporter did
ask an interesting question
why is joe biden on television demanding
a boycott
of an american state while not demanding
a boycott of china
after all the biden administration just
declared that china was committing
genocide against ethnic minorities
well joe biden's grumpy little flack
wasn't happy about that question
the president have voiced his support
for
mlb making a decision about the all-star
game in georgia
i'm wondering when can we expect a final
determination from the president
about the united states participating in
the beijing olympics given that he said
the chinese president doesn't have a
democratic bone in his body
well i think the u.s olympic committee
would play a big role in
on major league baseball here in the
united states he actually didn't i i
think i don't know if you heard the q
the answer the question the answer that
happened a few minutes ago where we
addressed this and
i answered the question so uh and i give
a little more context but maybe you
weren't paying attention to that part
i'm not going to answer the question
sentiment pretend that i already did and
you didn't hear it because you're dumb
it's your fault
we look there's no answer no one at the
white house explained why a law against
voter fraud in georgia
justifies a boycott but a genocide in
china does not
doesn't matter the domestic boycott
against georgia grows anyway huge parts
of corporate america have joined it
they've decided that georgia is
reinstating jim crow
here's a great one coca-cola which is
based in atlanta
now tells us that georgia's anti-voter
fraud law
is unacceptable let me be crystal clear
and unequivocal
this legislation is unacceptable
it is a step backwards and it does not
promote principles we have stood for in
georgia
around broad access to voting around
voter convenience
about ensuring election integrity and
this is this is frankly just a step
backwards
not clear how long the ceo of coca-cola
has been in this country but just to
restate just because you run a soft
drink company doesn't mean you get to
control our democracy
he may not know that it's a step
backward he told us which is pretty
funny if you think about it
so coca-cola is very very concerned
about black people
which makes you wonder since we're on
the subject how many black people have
died in the last hundred years from
diabetes caused by coca-cola products
we don't have those numbers someone
ought to find out we bet money it's far
more than the minneapolis police
department has killed ever
and here's the even funnier part china
is one of coca-cola's biggest markets
and that's why last year kurt ferguson
is the president of coca-cola greater
china and korea
went out of his way to praise the
communist party of china for unleashing
the coronavirus on the world
this is a verbatim quote thank you very
much to the government with your quick
decisive actions
once again thank you you've really
controlled a worldwide epidemic
and should be very much congratulated
for all your hard work
may i kiss your feet may i slobber on
you have a coke and a smile
unbelievable but coca-cola wants you to
believe that whatever's happening in
china it really cares
most about its type 2 diabetes victims
here in the united states
coca-cola hates discrimination okay
so why isn't coca-cola saying anything
about phil scott he's the governor of
vermont he's a republican by the way
this week governor scott declared that
vermont would be passing out vaccines on
the basis of skin color
vermont wants to check your racial
purity before they give you life-saving
medicine
well that doesn't seem like a good idea
or legal or
ethical or something that would ever
happen in america is coca-cola okay with
that apparently they are
you can still get a diet coke at
loonings in burlington great restaurant
by the way
coke hasn't said a word about it another
has delta
which despite being an airline and not a
super pac has also decided to condemn
georgia's elections bill according to
the ceo of delta
people in the black community are upset
about the law so of course delta is very
upset too
this is about protecting the voices of
our people
when i when i speak to our people
particularly within the black community
we're here in atlanta we've got a very
very large black employee base
almost universally they are
hurt by the the law and the legislation
that was enacted
and we need to make certain their voices
are heard we spent a lot of time in the
last year
reaching out to those most vulnerable
and telling them that we hear them
that we see them that their voices
matter
and if we can't stand with them now when
will we
yeah so he's just reading something the
hr department wrote for him but it
doesn't seem like he's paused to think
through the implications here so delta
airlines
operates because u.s taxpayers and the
congress lawmakers or democracy allow
delta ii can't just start an airline and
run it you need the cooperation of
the public but part of the deal is if
you're delta airlines or some other big
company benefiting from all the good
things that america offers is
you're not allowed to override the
democracy just because you're rich
you're not allowed to do that and if you
do maybe we should punish you
maybe we should delta says it's quote
very large black
employee base is almost universally hurt
by the law really did you take a poll
delta
remarkably and this is amazing that's
not what delta was saying about the very
same law a few days ago before the biden
administration
leaned on them at the time delta issued
a statement declaring quote
the legislation improved considerably
during the legislative process and
expands weekend voting codifies sunday
voting
and protects a voter's ability to cast
an absentee ballot without offering a
reason
delta even at the time praised the law's
protections for ballot drop boxes quote
for the first time drop boxes have also
been authorized for all counties
statewide and poll workers will be
allowed to work across county lines okay
before we even get into how they change
their view again this is an
airline why are they weighing in on a
voting law who do you think you are
delta airlines we should shut you down
now delta has decided the law doesn't
meet its standards requiring voter
identification
says delta is jim crow but wait a minute
you might be wondering
doesn't delta airlines require photo id
in order to board its planes
oh that sounds like jim crow why isn't
that racist
because it's not shut up one of the
democratic party's top election law
enforcers a trollish man called mark
elias tried to answer that question on
twitter quote
the new georgia law will require voters
to submit id
to vote by mail he wrote if they use
their driver's license they need to
provide the number
one of the two numbers below is correct
if they put the
other down it will be rejected are you
sure you would pick the right one
elias posted a photograph of a sample
driver's license below his tweet and the
implication is pretty clear
according to marcoliz black people can't
find their driver's license number even
when it's clearly identified
on the driver's license card mark elias
like delta
just doesn't think they can read it so
who's the racist
in the story seriously when you treat
adults like children
what does that say about how you feel
about them